the de voto prison in the city of Venice
is taken over inmates hundreds of them
on the rooftop of the only prison in the
city we need help
we don't want to die here they said
we're not animals
one guard tested positive in the past
week and prisoners say they fear for
their lives water and electricity has
been cut off the prisoners say there are
many who have chronic diseases and need
to be put under house arrest prisons in
Argentina already have a history of
overcrowding and lack of sanitation and
this one would be in seeing the
prisoners throwing rocks and the police
responding you serve rubber bullets we
also heard several explosions inside and
rest have been on the rise in prisons in
this countries as inmates are fearful of
the spread of kovat 19 the inmates
relatives came to show their support
they want their loved ones released they
try to cross the cordoned area the
police did not allow them my husband has
HIV and he should be at home right now
they're going to kill him in there
a federal court in Argentina recommended
granting house arrest to prisoners
convicted for nonviolent crimes or
sentenced to less than three years
behind bars due to the risks of
coronavirus pandemic the measure was
questioned by relatives of crime victims
this is not the only prison affected
there are at least eight others were
inmates are on hunger strike coronavirus
is a major test for governments in Latin
America prisons are just one of the many
challenges ahead terasawa
al Jazeera Buenos Aires